[Música]
olá obrigado a todos ainda estão
entusiasmados porque acho que estou
batendo um recorde do guinness
ontem foi o dia de recordes do guinness
há um mês atrás nunca tinha dado uma
tese ex top e esta é a quarta em quatro
pecs todas diferentes em sítios
diferentes línguas diferentes até em
menos de um mês
uma verdadeira maratona mas eu já estou
habituado a maratonas e ultramaratonas
faça o trabalho torna de atenção por
causa de cuidar e orgulho em dizer que
sou a única mulher portuguesa que já fez
a travessia de problemas até peniche que
é mais dura em portugal continental foi
em agosto 2017 que foi preciso cuidar e
aprovam guarda voluntário de fish para a
cercipeniche em setembro de 2008 na
primeira semana eu fiz não uma mas duas
outra maratona alimentação solidário é
algo que não consegue que eles vão
entrar em recessão
duas outras maratonas de uma semana
mas quem vê a fonte para a seção
alzheimer portugal como é que eu faço
isto como um treino físico obviamente
são muitas horas de treino todos os dias
mas também como entrar mental e aptidão
física está em falar hoje pela
encenadora e ultra maratonista também
melhorou a cientista instrutora do
twitter são mais força
sempre fui muito curiosa desde pequenina
sempre saber tudo e aprender tudo com
três anos apenas já sabia ler e escrever
o cérebro sempre me fascinou eu pensava
que eu sabia que um dia iria de verdade
os mistérios do cérebro de vida é muito
curiosa e dá muitas voltas quando há
seis anos apenas que vem nossa sociedade
vive para uma copa demais países
estou sinceramente grata por isso mudar
para a ásia para que o exotismo na
consciência mudou completamente a minha
vida
curiosa ela está queria viver a
experiência ao máximo e aprender tudo
pudesse então tudo
trair sobre o budismo taoísmo
confucionismo em cima e perceberam
nenhum ser xingado chance filmes
organiza tudo que o que entra em anjos
figo vista ea maneira oriental de estar
na vida sempre pra mim o vídeo numa
região mais uma maneira de estar na vida
e valores como a compaixão ea gratidão e
humildade pilares essenciais das
culturas asiáticas tornaram se também os
pilares da minha existência
ao começar a portugal
eu percebi que tudo mudará e que minha
vida nunca mais seria a mesma
a terminar a licenciatura é menor e
curiosidades sobre o cérebro vão
novamente para longe
fui para londres quando fiz o mestrado
em engenharia biomédica no inter o
volante e depois pro filadélfia onde fez
o doutoramento em neurociência e
universo equipe venceu vania daire links
e lá está mais uma vez que aprender tudo
ao máximo e trabalhar dia e noite em
vários laboratórios em áreas tão
distintas como neurocirurgia em adquirir
o mar fica sempre por encontrar um dia a
discar cérebros humanos e minorias irão
construir cérebros em silicone mas aqui
o que realmente interessava eram os
processos cognitivos mais complexo do
que o que nos torna humano filho único
interessava me a consciência e passava
horas naquelas fabulosas bibliotecas da
universidade estudar a consciência eo
filme da mente lembrava defensivo disse
tim aprendido anos antes na ásia e desde
então tenta relacionar e conciliar estes
dois mundos como face no a neurociência
eo budismo em 2005 é ainda durante o
apuramento
o meu trabalho foi premiado e tive a
honra de ser foi acionada para dar uma
palestra na maior e melhor conferência
de neurociência site for neuroscience
com poucos jogadores mas são 35 mil
pessoas na audiência
e curiosamente não por coincidência tipo
nada acontece por acaso
nesse ano eu acho que eu disse foi
iniciado uma série de palestras
intitulado de algo sempre neurose
assistidas pode convidar um líder e
outras áreas com interesse para a
neurociência e quem foi convidado pra
palestra inaugural pelo mesmo o dalai
lama para falar sobre neuroses essa
indicação
eu estava a strans desde que meu
doutoramento em 2007
tenho dedicados a estudar a relação
entre a neurose a 5 de junho e os
infantis da meditação no cérebro em 2016
se história meditação forma formal vai
de pouco já tinha milhares e milhares de
horas de experiência já faço isso há
quase 30 anos e já tinha muita
investigação feita sobre o assunto mas
queria mesmo tornarmos uma estrutura
simplificada melancia
então vou fazer o famoso curso mais como
vai se transferir do chan
o programa de oito semanas desenvolvido
por jonny cabacinha sobre mérito da
harvard medical school
mas como gosto maratonas em vez de fazer
em oito semanas fiz em apenas uma opção
intensiva seguida de uma semana de um
dia de silêncio é uma experiência e
brutal que o conselho todos vocês um
pouco mais tarde fiz mais um curso para
ser instrutor e a bsa
foi incrível
voltou tudo se sentindo
finalmente capaz de juntar as peças do
complexo favor pense da minha existência
explicar o consignado alinhar da querida
o my phone mas não cita de ser
completado com qualquer crença religiosa
mas a verdade é que tem as suas raízes
em práticas budistas as estradas do
sudeste asiático
ao estudar formalmente
eu percebi que uma informação é
basicamente por em prática na vida
cotidiana os ensinamentos do budismo 0
eu tinha absorvido e entranhado forma
tão profunda no meu corpo e minha alma
nada de chances sempre um novo em casa
já no cavaquinho fim mãe fuma como
continha sic merss através da tomada da
tensão forma intencional no momento
presente e sem julgamento ao desenrolar
da experiência momento o momento o maior
fã dessa ajuda nos a controlar a nossa
atenção para as emissões e desenvolver
uma melhor consciência de nós próprios e
também dos outros e daquilo que nos
rodeia através de técnicas de imagem o
fia como relacionamento profissional é
possível encontrar no cérebro áreas que
estão associadas às três componentes do
marfim fãs para controlar a tensão que
temos o córtex anterior do sim o corpo
estriado para a redução das emissões
várias áreas do córtex pré frontal e
pára a autoconsciência isso a 5 exterior
e cunha e também o porta-voz pré frontal
também aqui a mídia até uma zona do
cérebro que está associado ao
processamento de emoções negativas
ora sabe que pessoas e animais têm vidas
muito estressante tenha níveis maiores
do que a média
pegaram grupos no grupo de ratos e os
pusemos no ambiente muito interessantes
uma gaiola com muito ruído durante duas
semanas a xuxa - crescem durante pelo
menos 10% maior em 10 por cento em duas
semanas apenas conseguem compreender o
que os três fazem os nossos serviços
hoje como ver um dos animais do ambiente
recebe voltarmos a concordo com os
outros não se consegue adaptar se exibir
um comportamento mais ou menos normal
mas as suas amigas nunca regressam ao
tamanho original
por outro lado os amigos praticando
experientes limitação são mais pequenas
do que a média e é por isso que as
pessoas prefiram habitação conseguem
compreender melhor chutando os
pensamentos e controlar melhor as suas
funções na europa se darão um concerto
tabu até há pouco tempo pensava-se que o
cérebro é imutável
os sábios e flexível é capaz de se
adaptar e com digitação o cérebro muda
se divertir
a meditação muito aos nossos cérebros
está demonstrado que uma prática
sustentável acreditação prime ter o
genus ou seja o nascimento de novos
neurônios e o aumento da densidade de
matéria cinzenta entre determinadas
áreas do nosso cérebro e para mim também
é ensinar protógenes
o crescimento de novas sinapses e com 50
e organização cerebral como habitação a
neuroplasticidade e como meditação nos
permitir reorganizar o nosso cérebro
prometemos também alterar a
neurobiologia do nosso pensamento
cogitação podemos tornar-nos mais
bondoso e compassivo e podemos
substituir pensamentos negativos e que
os processos cognitivos estão associadas
a síndromes de ansiedade e depressão por
outros processos pensamento mais
saudáveis influência e tornaram-se
também nós mais soldados
e é com grande felicidade com os tipos
que hoje a neurociência está a
demonstrar aquilo que o budismo 10 tem
vindo a dizer há milhares de anos
prestar atenção ao momento presente
estar aqui e agora é o caminho da
felicidade
a felicidade está nas nossas mãos
cada vez que temos um pensamento em vez
de outro estamos a escolher ser ou não
influência cada vez que alimentar os
pensamentos negativos e como inativos
que estamos a caminhar para um cenário
negro de ansiedade e depressão
cada vez que eu entramos com pensamento
positivo excluiria regras
estamos a caminhar para a felicidade da
compaixão pega nas nossas palestras do
curso
soltem o artista que há dentro de vocês
y qualquer voz é certo porque querem a
vossa vida
vou agora convidar vos fazer um
exercício sempre uma posição confortável
costas direitas encostados à cadeira
mãos no colo bem assentes no chão
vou pedir que fechem os olhos se chamará
vamos respirar fundo
concentra-se na nossa inspiração assim
que o ar entrar depoente
vamos fazer um exercício de tensão o
foco é a vossa atenção nos vossos feche
sintomas nos filhos sim tons de verde
brinca com os dedos de tanto tempo não
brincava com eles
sinto o contato dos pés com o chão
sinto agora os vossos tornozelos e as
pernas de canelas dos pernas
os quadros nos cochos em contato com o
call center e dor em cinco jogos
se fosse feito
sinto novamente o ar entrar e encher os
pulmões passa agora para a vossa cabeça
e observam os votos vencidos
observe a noite fora quando estivesse em
cima de uma ponte sobre uma via fé haver
um longo comboio passar pensamento
prender só um pensamento é como saltar
da ponte é a raça uma carruagem esse
viagem com ela não é isso que
pretendemos e copa podemos ficar apenas
observar em cima do pensamento que vier
a ter conhecido tentaram hop
o conforto está cada pensamento que vier
com o mal
segundo com gratidão não ofereçam
resistência deixem entrar mas não entre
em algumas viaduto tempo deixe de
treinar em assim a vossa meninas irão
ser capaz de reconhecer os vossos
pensamentos assim que o xuxa irão
aprender a lidar com eles irão também
aprender a selecionar que pensamentos
quer entreter mas querem manter e
alimentar tal como se preocupam com
aquilo que comem com os alimentos que
dão a voz corpo devem preocupar-se com
os pensamentos com os quais alimentam o
vosso cérebro
vou pedir que agora pensa em uma pessoa
que ama enviemos amor estão certamente
sentir uma onda de calor com paixão e
felicidade
o vosso corpo como se todo o corpo
peço agora que tenta expandir a nossa
consciência expandir essa onda de
compaixão a todos os que estão nesta
sala o município de conhecidos
sinto uma compaixão a vossa e dos outros
sintomas nos vossos corações pensa em
como seria bom se conseguisse estar
sempre assim a publicar esta sensação
que estou a ter rendimentos pensa em
como seria bom que todos os seres
humanos tivessem sempre assim que fossem
montadas e com tecidos podem abrir os
olhos
no mundo em que podemos ser o que
quisermos
eu escolhi ser compreensiva generosa e
altruísta
escolhi fazer desafios desportivos por
causas solidárias
pra mim a compaixão é como uma religião
e é por isso que se fazer a minha
própria instituição de impacto social
promover a saúde física e mental da
população e promover valores como a
compaixão e gratidão pessoas física e
mentalmente mais saudáveis são mais
fluência e constroem as cidades mais
harmoniosas mais sustentáveis e mais
produtivos contribuindo assim para uma
melhor economia e prosperidade nacional
e contribuindo também para a paz mundial
e com viso dalai lama se ensinar somos
todas as crianças de 8 anos acreditar
que conseguiríamos iluminar a violência
do mundo em apenas uma geração querem
ajudar a concretizar o meu projeto trata
também do vosso servo aprendam a meditar
tenham compaixão
sejam felizes obrigado
[Aplausos]